meine Damen und Herren liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen ich wünsche einen schönen
guten Morgen die Sitzung ist eröffnet
die gestern in erster Lesung
der gestern in erster Lesung beratende
Gesetzentwurf zur Änderung des
heizkostenzuschussgesetzes und des 11
Buches Sozialgesetzbuch auf Drucksache
3.884 soll nachträglich auch dem
Ausschuss für Bildung Forschung und
Technikfolgenabschätzung überwiesen
werden sehe sie sind damit einverstanden
kein Widerspruch dann ist das so
beschlossen
ich rufe auf die Zusatzpunkte 8 und 9
erste Beratung des von den Fraktionen
SPD Bündnis 90 die Grünen und FDP
eingebrachten Gesetzentwurf zur Änderung
des
stabilisierungsvorgesetztes zur
Reaktivierung und Neuausrichtung des
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds sowie
Beratung des Antrags der Fraktion der
AFD mit dem Titel keine neuen
Schattenhaushalte begründen für die
Aussprache ist eine Dauer von 39 Minuten
vereinbart
ich eröffne die Aussprache und das Wort
hat zuerst der Parlamentarische
Staatssekretär Dr Florian Tonka für die
Bundesregierung
herzlichen Dank Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir haben über
den Sommer und bis heute anhaltend enorm
hohe Energiepreise und insgesamt eine
bisher in den letzten 70 Jahren nicht
mehr gekannte Entwicklung der Inflation
wir sind zurzeit auf Monatsbasis bei 10%
gesehen sie sind weit überwiegend Folge
des russischen angriffskriegs auf die
Ukraine und Folge der Strategie der
russischen Führung Europa auch
Deutschland über steigende Energiepreise
über das Abschneiden von Gaslieferungen
politisch und wirtschaftlich unter Druck
zu setzen unsere Gesellschaft zu
destabilisieren um selbst Erfolg zu
haben den sie in ihrer Kriegsführung
bisher nicht gehabt haben diese
Strategie darf nicht aufgehen und wir
verfügen über die Mittel auch zu
verhindern dass diese Strategie aufgeht
und das in unserem Land aufgrund der
russischen Energiepolitik und der
russischen Kriegspolitik Existenzen
gefährdet und vernichtet werden und
genau darum geht es heute mit diesen
Abwehrschirm über den wir debattieren
[Applaus]
Herzstück der Vorschläge ist eine
Gaspreis und eine strompreisbremse an
der Konzeption wird mit Hochdruck
gearbeitet das wurde ja auch diese Woche
schon debattiert hier im Haus natürlich
ist die beste Gaspreis und die beste
strompreisbremse Angebot schaffen und
Verbrauch reduzieren beides zusammen
denken beides zusammen denken
und dennoch und dennoch wird es nötig
sein dass der Staat zusätzlich Mittel
mobilisiert um die Folgen für unsere
Gesellschaft abzufedern und um den
Übergang um eine Brücke auch in eine
wieder dauerhaft verlässliche
nachhaltige und bezahlbare
Energieversorgung zu haben dafür
schlagen wir vor dass 200 Milliarden
Euro bereitgestellt werden über den
bereits in der Pandemie eingeführten
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds der
dafür modifiziert werden soll die
Maßnahmen die wir vorschlagen sollen in
den Jahren noch 2022 überwiegend 2023
und dann 2024 finanziert werden also es
geht darum eine Brücke über die nächsten
beiden Winter zu bauen die Regelung über
den WSF Mittel bereitzustellen hat
enorme Vorteile zum einen kann man auf
diese Weise ein starkes Signal setzen
einen Betrag der ausreicht um die um die
Notwendigkeiten abzudecken bereitstellen
auch überjährig und mit starken Signal
mit der Verlässlichkeit dass die Mittel
eben auch da sind beeinflussen wir auch
Inflationserwartungen so dass das was
wir hier machen der Abwehrschirm auch
eine inflationsbremse ist gerade weil er
dieses starke Signal sendet
und zum zweiten
sind die Mittel die der WSF verwenden
soll strengt zweckgebunden es ist eben
so dass es ganz genau für die vier im
Gesetz vorgeschlagenen Zwecke
gaspreisbremse strompreisbremse
unternehmenshilfen und Unterstützung der
KfW ausgegeben werden darf und auch für
nichts anderes und insofern schaffen wir
es auch die Ressourcen die wir jetzt
mobilisieren müssen wirklich gezielt für
die Bewältigung der Energiekrise und der
Preisspirale einzusetzen und auch für
nichts anderes als das und das ist auch
richtig und wichtig und funktioniert
über den WSF sehr gut
wir haben ich habe schon gesagt vier
Instrumente gaspreisbremse die
strompreisbremse wobei wir bei der
strompreisbremse das ist auch sehr
wichtig für die finanziellen Themen die
wir hier sprechen ja auch mit Einnahmen
rechnen wir wollen die zufallsgewinne
abschöpfen und damit natürlich auch
insbesondere den Strompreis an anderer
Stelle entlasten aber es soll nicht
alleine nur ein Zuschuss sein und wir
haben bei den
unternehmensstützungsmaßnahmen natürlich
auch
Beteiligungen die wir eingehen wo man
auch mit Ausgaben aber auch mit
Einnahmen rechnen kann insofern ist auch
noch nicht gesagt aufgrund der
Zusammensetzung der Instrumente wie es
am Ende finanziell ausgehen wird wir
haben ganz klare Ausgaben vor allem im
Bereich der gaspreisbremse und wir haben
einige Instrumente wo es zu Ausgaben
kommen wird aber potenziell jedenfalls
auch zu Einnahmen und ich kann Ihnen
sagen das Bundesfinanzministerium wird
die Möglichkeiten auch Rückflüsse auch
Einnahmen auch Refinanzierung bei den
jeweiligen Instrumenten zu nutzen genau
im Blick behalten und auch zu nutzen
versuchen wir werden ganz klar mit dem
Beschluss über dieses Gesetz nochmals
auch feststellen müssen dass wir uns in
einer außergewöhnlichen Notsituation
befinden die sich der Kontrolle des
Staates entzieht und die staatliche
Finanzlage erheblich beeinträchtigt
Artikel 115 Grundgesetz das hat sich das
ist bereits geltende Beschlusslage
dieses Bundestages für das Jahr 2022 und
die Lage hat sich durch den
vollständigen Wegfall russischer
Gaslieferungen Ende August ja nochmals
deutlich verschärft insofern ist der
erforderliche Veranlassungszusammenhang
zwischen Notlage und den Ausgaben die
wir hier tätigen aus unserer Sicht auch
evident gegeben und rechtfertigt dieses
Engagement es geht darum Schaden von
unserem Land abzuwenden es geht darum
Existenzen zu sichern private Existenzen
wie unternehmerische Existenzen das ist
erstmal ein wichtiges Ziel als solches
aber wenn wir unternehmerische
Existenzen insbesondere auch sichern
Unternehmen helfen durch diese Zeit zu
kommen dann sichern wir uns auch
Steuersubstrat und Einnahmen für die
nächsten Jahre insofern ist es auch
unter dem Gesichtspunkt nachhaltiger
staatlicher Finanzen geboten und
verantwortbar das zu tun was wir hier
vorschlagen ich freue mich auf die
parlamentarischen Beratungen und bedanke
mich für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
das war Florian Tonka der
Parlamentarische Staatssekretär aus dem
Finanzministerium der hier diesen
Gesetzentwurf vorgestellt hat Matthias
Mittelberg für die
cdu/csu-stellvertretender
Fraktionsvorsitzender für den Bereich
Haushalt
es ist gut und das sage ich vorweg dass
die gaspreisbremse jetzt kommt aber man
muss auch dazu sagen endlich kommt sie
sie haben viel Zeit verbraucht in diesem
Sommer mit internen Streitereien bis sie
endlich zu dieser Lösung gekommen sind
sie haben jetzt eine Variante gefunden
aufgrund des Vorschlags der Kommission
Grundbedarf 80% des vorjahresverbrauchs
werden preislich gedeckelt auf 12 Cent
das ist eine Lösung die wir auch
durchaus sachgemäß und richtig finden
sie entspricht auch dem Beschluss
unseres cdu-bundesparteitages schon vom
9 September
als wir beschlossen haben dass wir 75
Prozent des Grundbedarfs zu 12 Cent
preislich absichern oder Deckeln wollen
so nun haben sie allerdings so viel Zeit
gebraucht für ihre
gaspreisbremse dass die gaspreisbremse
wirklich dann in Kraft tritt wenn die
Menschen Sie wirklich brauchen nämlich
im März wenn der Winter weitgehend
hinter uns ist das ist das Ergebnis
ihrer politischen Arbeitsleistung und
das müssen sie sich schon vorhalten
lassen die richtigen Lösungsvorschläge
lagen also lange auf dem Tisch sie haben
nur viel zu lange gebraucht um diese
Wege zu erkennen ich sage ausdrücklich
Respekt gegenüber der Kommission
gegenüber der Arbeit der Kommission die
sehr zügig jetzt gearbeitet hat das
gleiche kann man eben von ihrer
Regierungsarbeit wirklich nicht sagen
noch im Juli
noch im Juli und das müssen wir uns alle
in Erinnerung rufen da ist der
Bundeskanzler hat ja sogar seinen Urlaub
unterbrochen ist extra hier nach Berlin
gefahren und hat eine ganz große
Neuigkeit verkündet das ist nämlich
jetzt die gaspreisbremse das ist die
gasumlage gibt so das hat er dann
verbunden auch mit seinem bekannten Satz
you'll never walk alone das ist ja eine
tolle Aussage da konnten die Leute auf
einmal verstehen dass meint ich habe
nicht nur die höheren Gaspreise sondern
ich kriege auch noch die Umlage
obendrauf you never walk alone du
kriegst noch die Umlage oben drauf als
fetten zusätzlichen belastungsrucksack
das war ursprünglich ja das war
ursprünglich ihr politischer Ansatz sie
wollten den Leuten die Preise noch
zusätzlich erhöhen dann haben sie
monatelang intern gestritten und jetzt
haben sie endlich erkannt was richtig
ist setzen es um aber jetzt brauchen wir
natürlich Monate in der Umsetzung wenn
sie im Juli klug reagiert hätten und
klug gehandelt hätten dann hätten wir
die gaspreisbremse jetzt schon und sie
würde passend zum Winter in Kraft treten
beim Thema angebots-
[Applaus]
der Herr Tonka völlig zu Recht
angesprochen da passiert aber bei ihnen
so gut wie nichts sie haben auch da
monatelang gebraucht bis sie unserem
Antrag gefolgt sind den Deckel bei der
Biomasse wegzunehmen sie haben gesagt
sie wollen die Kohlekraftwerke
hochfahren davon sind in Deutschland
gerade zwei mittlerweile am Start
tatsächlich und dann diskutieren sie
noch immer über die Weiternutzung von
drei Kernkraftwerken die jetzt noch
laufen und die die Versorgung von 10
Millionen Bürgern in diesem Land
sicherstellen ich sage auch vor den
Risiken eines wirklichen möglichen
Blackouts ihr Verhalten dazu ist
vollkommen verantwortungslos das 80
Millionen Bundesbürger jetzt noch darauf
warten müssen was ein grüner Parteitag
beschließt das sage ich Ihnen ganz
ehrlich das ist völlig unverantwortlich
für eine Regierungspartei
ihre ich habe eben die Arbeit der
Kommission gelobt und sie setzen jetzt
bei der gaspreisbremse die Arbeit dieser
Kommission deckungsgleich um das haben
sie jetzt jedenfalls so gesagt
maßgebliche Kraft in dieser Kommission
ist Frau Professor Grimm die diese
Konzepte erarbeitet hat dieselbe Frau
Professor Grimm die dem Rat der
Wirtschaftsweisen angehört hat
ausgerechnet wenn wir die drei
Kernkraftwerke weiter nutzen wird der
Strompreis um 8 bis 12 Prozent gesenkt
dass sie diese strompreissenkung den
Bürgern verwehren wollen ist ein Skandal
und nun
und nun zum letzten Punkt man sieht das
dem Kollegen Tonka bildlich nicht an das
ist auch gut so hätte ich fast gesagt
aber die Art und Weise wie sie jetzt
dieses
schuldenkonglomerat sie der eine nennt
das ja doppelwumms der andere spricht
jetzt vom Abwehrschirm sie müssen sich
damit der Titulatur noch einig werden
aber das ist ja das worüber wir heute
eigentlich im Kern sprechen dass wir 200
Milliarden Schulden aufnehmen ohne dass
wir genau wissen wofür das Geld
eigentlich ausgegeben werden soll aber
dazu wollen sie schon mal unsere
Zustimmung haben und was Sie jetzt tun
ist ohne dass Sie wirklich wissen was
finanziert werden soll laden Sie sich
die Hamsterbacken erstmal voll mit einem
schuldenvorrat da werden die Taschen
voll geladen in diesem Jahr es wird auch
alles auf dieses Jahr gerechnet 2022
damit der Finanzminister dann im
nächsten Jahr künstlich sagen kann ich
halte die Schuldenbremse ein das ist
eigentlich der Hammer in diesem Jahr
insgesamt machen wir 500 Milliarden
zusätzliche Schulden die 200 Milliarden
doppelwumms die 100 Milliarden für die
Bundeswehr dann machen wir die 140
milliar die sie jetzt im regulären
Haushalt machen und dann haben sie sich
noch die 60 Milliarden aus dem letzten
Jahr geklaut das sind zusammen 500
Milliarden den Schuldenstand des Bundes
erhöhen wir damit um ein Drittel das ist
die höchste Verschuldung die wir
überhaupt jeden einem Jahr in
Deutschland gemacht haben absoluter
superrekord das alles wird jetzt
gerechnet auf dieses Jahr
ausgegeben werden die Gelder tatsächlich
in den nächsten Jahren und da sage ich
Ihnen das ist ein Finanzierungsweg den
wir so nicht mitgehen werden was wir in
der was sie in der Sache tun
gaspreisbremse ist richtig der
Finanzierungsweg ist nicht okay vielen
Dank
der Bundestag debattiert über die
Änderung des stabilisierungs
fondsgesetzes er soll er tüchtigt werden
nämlich mit 200 Milliarden Euro die im
Übrigen in diesem Jahr noch abgestimmt
werden sollen und der nächste rednerste
stellvertretende Fraktionsvorsitzende
nein ist er nicht
jetzt kann man selber gucken liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren Herr Dr
Mittelberg ich möchte zu Hause dass wir
uns in einer Krise befinden die es in
dieser Form das hatten sie in einem
kleinen Satz in ihrer Rede auch erwähnt
so noch nicht gehabt haben und vor dem
Hintergrund gab es erstens keine
Blaupausen die wir aus der Schublade
hätten hätten ziehen können um nur zu
sagen reibungslos in Krisenmanagement zu
installieren und zweitens und zweitens
haben wir als Ampelkoalition in dieser
Zeit bis jetzt
Entlastungsmaßnahmen auf den Weg
gebracht über drei entlastungspakete
über unterschiedliche Ebenen Weg
Einmalzahlungen wir haben
Steuerentlastungen auf die Beine
gestellt wir haben am Ende die
EEG-Umlage abgeschafft wir haben
Mehrwertsteuersätze gesehen für die
Gastronomie und für für die Gaspreise
etc pp das ist etwas wo wir an dieser
Stelle in erheblicher Weise dazu
beigetragen haben die Menschen an dieser
Stelle schon zu entlasten und jetzt
liegt was vor womit wir einen nächsten
einen wie ich finde auch entscheidenden
Schritt gehen können wir können mit der
Umwandlung des
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds mit der
Funktion mit der Erweiterung auf einen
Abwehrschirm hin mit 200 Milliarden Euro
die Menschen entlasten die es am
dringendsten brauchen genau die die
jetzt in Unsicherheit und Angst schweben
die Unternehmen die an dieser Stelle von
Unsicherheit geprägt sind und nicht
wissen wie sie ihre wirtschaftlichen
weiteren Monate planen sollen die jetzt
ihre Abschlagszahlungen für das nächste
Jahr vorliegen haben diesen helfen wir
mit dieser Erweiterung über die 200
Milliarden Euro weil wir Ihnen in
erheblicher Weise bei der stemmung beim
stemmen und bei der Unterstützung der
des Bezahlens der Energie Gas und
Strompreise helfen können und das ist
etwas wo diese Regierung keine Zeit vor
trödelt hat wo wir uns im Rahmen der
vorhandenen Möglichkeiten eben auf diese
Expertenkommission bezogen haben und
jetzt ist
gesetzesmöglichkeit da das zu verändern
und deswegen kann ich sie jetzt schon
darum bitten dieser Gesetz diesem
Gesetzentwurf zuzustimmen
was ich hier was ich hier aber auch noch
mal hervorheben möchte ist und wir haben
es ja an ihrer Rede auch gerade wieder
gehört während in dieser man muss ja so
schon sagen einzigartigen Krise in
dieser Staats- und Wirtschaftskrise in
der wir gerade sind alles zusammen getan
werden muss damit wir unsere
staatspolitischen Verantwortung als
Parlament insgesamt nachkommen können
gibt es einige in diesem Haus die haben
ganz andere Interessenlagen ich wünschte
mir gerade von ihrer Fraktion weil sie
in der Vergangenheit ja also bei der
corona-krisenbewältigung einige
Instrumente ja auf dem Weg gebracht
haben die uns damals gut geholfen haben
dass sie in dieser gleichen Konsequenz
auch heute hinter den Maßnahmen der
Regierung stehen weil wir da natürlich
auch eine ganz andere Kraft nach draußen
an die Bürgerinnen und Bürger vermelden
können das zweite und es will ich aber
auch sagen ist
dass wir dass wir auch Abgeordnete vor
allem aus ihrer Fraktion der AFD haben
die diese existenzielle Krise der
Bürgerinnen und Bürger der Unternehmen
dafür nutzen durch durch
verschwörungsmythen durch durch Lügen
durch Hetze die Bevölkerung in ihrer
unsicheren Lage sogar noch dagegen
aufzubringen sie spalten die
Gesellschaft ihr Geschäftsmodell ist es
diese Krise zu nutzen und die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger in ihren Sorgen
zu benutzen um ihr politisches Kalkül
daraus zu ziehen und das ist einfach
schäbig
die Ampelkoalition hat sich an dieser
Stelle zu einem großen Maßnahmepaket
verständigt und ich denke dass wir mit
dem Wirtschaft Stabilisierungsfonds in
der Umwandlung zum Abwehrschirm einen
weiteren wichtigen Schritt gehen wir
werden das sagte ich schon die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger die dringend
darauf warten sie alle warten darauf zu
wissen was wird mit den Rechnungen ab
September ab Januar für das nächste Jahr
dieses Geld was wir jetzt locker machen
können über diese Gesetzesänderung wird
Ihnen helfen damit sie ihre Rechnung
besser bezahlen können das ist der
richtige Weg das ist der Kurs den Olaf
Scholz und diese Ampelkoalition
einschlägt damit helfen wir den Menschen
und überbrücken eine nächste wichtige
Zeit und wir wissen alle in dieser
Ampelkoalition weil wir uns
verantwortungsbewusst dieser Krise
stellen dass wir offen für die
Notwendigkeiten sind auch nächste und
weitere Schritte durchzugehen wenn sie
denn nötig sind die 200 Milliarden Euro
mit dieser Modifizierung des
wirtschaftsstabilisierungs ist zumindest
ein nächster ein guter ein wichtiger
Schritt und ich bitte Sie noch mal um
Zustimmung in diesem Gesetz vielen Dank
und das war natürlich Frank junge meine
Damen und Herren ich bitte nochmal
entschuldigung das war wirklich
innerhalb von Sekunden getauscht ich
sehe Matthias mürschte reden sollte auch
nicht im Plenum vielleicht kann er nicht
da sein ist nicht da insofern ist Frank
junge da scheinbar eingesprungen Peter
Böhringer jetzt der haushaltspolitische
Sprecher der afd-fraktion
frau Präsidentin liebe Mitbürger die
Regierung weiß gar nicht was konkret Sie
heute hier vorlegt jedenfalls sagt sie
es uns im Gesetzestext nicht im Entwurf
ergibt sich die Bundesregierung in Wagen
Andeutungen über staatliche Programme
zur Abfederung von Preissteigerungen
beim Bezug von Gas und Strom aber es
gibt darin nicht ein Wort wie diese
Programme ausgestaltet werden sollten
wer bekommt Geld welche Preise werden wo
gedeckelt wie soll die Sache operativ
umgesetzt werden all das werden Fragen
die dieser Bundestag natürlich wissen
müsste bevor über solche gewaltige
Verschuldung auch nur debattiert werden
kann
das vorgelegte Gesetz wird das ist
bereits sicher ein bürokratisches
Monstrum hervorbringen der
eigentümerverband Haus und Grund
bezeichnet das Vorhaben der
gaspreiskommission als nicht umsetzbar
es sei von Leuten erarbeitet die noch
nie eine Heizkostenabrechnung gesehen
haben
dieser Bundestag soll zustimmen dass 200
Milliarden Euro neue Schulden in einen
zweckentfremdeten nebenhaushalt ich sage
bewusst auch Schattenhaushalt gepackt
werden es ist absurd der Regierung mal
eben über den Verordnungsweg einen
halben Jahreshaushalt freizugeben und
selbst diese Riesensumme wird nur für
etwa 15 Monate ausreichen wir sagen nein
zu diesem Blankoscheck
die AFD kann der Neuauflage des WSF
nicht zustimmen der doch 2020
ausschließlich gegen die angebliche
Jahrhundertkatastrophe namens Corona ins
Leben gerufen wurde oder in ihren Worten
Herr Tonka ihre Zitat von eben die
Mittel sind strikt zweckgebunden ja
genauso klang das auch im März 2020 an
dieser Stelle genau zum gleichen
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds die
Mittel sind strikt auf Corona
zweckgebunden was daraus wurde sehen wir
ja heute
die nun geplante Reaktivierung Umwidmung
und Vergrößerung auf Pump und auf Vorrat
des WSF ist Rainer Missbrauch einer
Notstandslage man will mit
exekutivmaßnahmen also Verordnung ohne
Rücksicht auf Zwänge knappen steuergelds
durchregieren das hat mit
parlamentarischer Kontrolle nichts mehr
zu tun
das Gasheizer auch noch bevorzugt werden
gegenüber ölheizen ja das macht das
Projekt rechtlich sogar noch weiter
angreifbar die planwirtschaftlichen
Maßnahmen von Strom und gaspreisdeckeln
sind vermeidbar die energiepression ist
Politik gemacht noch können Sie die
kommende Massenverarmung verhindern
indem sie endlich die Ursachen abstellen
für eine nur symptomatische Linderung
mit Steuergeld sind die Schadensummen
der aktuellen falschpolitik viel zu hoch
nötig ist also das Abwenden der für
menschenunternehmen existenziell
gefährlichen energienotstands des
energienotstands im Winters sie müssen
endlich den Irrweg der co2-modelltheorie
verlassen also heimische Kohle nutzen
zudem sichere Kernkraft sie müssen in
dieser Lage auch die für Deutschland so
verteilen Sanktionen gegen russisches Öl
und Gas aufgeben konkret muss auch wenn
sie es alle nicht hören wollen sofort
der noch intakt des Strang von Nords
schön genutzt werden über 30 Millionen
30 Millionen gasabnehmer in Deutschland
könnten alleine nur dadurch sofort
kostengünstig versorgt werden so wie es
die letzten Jahre auch immer war das
liegt im Interesse Deutschlands und
Europas da nur dieses pipeline-gas
wirklich Versorgungssicherheit
ermöglicht
die Regierung hofft stattdessen auf
einen warmen Winter als auf die böse
Erwärmung die man doch eigentlich
verhindern will und bekämpfen will
sie hofft auch auf Gas ausgerechnet aus
Katar und als arbeitshan obwohl wir doch
angeblich wertebasierte Außenpolitik
machen will sie hofft auf polnischen
Kohlestrom den man doch eigentlich
ablehnt und sie hofft auf französische
Kernkraft die man doch eigentlich hasst
und bekämpft so absurd ist deutsche
Regierungspolitik und auch
Oppositionspolitik
2122 herzlichen Dank
200 Milliarden Euro ertüchtigen soll der
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds erfahren
darum geht die Diskussion hier ist wenn
Christian kindner von den Bündnis grünen
haushaltspolitische Sprecher ist der
nächste Redner meine Damen und Herren
wir befinden uns in der schwersten Krise
seit Jahrzehnten
die corona-pandemie ist noch lange nicht
vorbei und die Klimakatastrophen das
Arten aussterben eskaliert immer mehr
wir haben diesen Sommer gesehen was das
heißt bei brennen in Brandenburg bei
Fremden Harz der Rhein ist ausgetrocknet
vor Dorte Feder die schlimmste Dürre
seit 500 Jahren in Europa und als wäre
das alles noch nicht schlimm genug für
das russische Regime ein brutalen
Angriffskrieg gegen die Ukrain gegen die
demokratische Ukraine
und das führt zu einer harten Krise auf
fossile Energie in Europa denn russische
Diktator Wladimir Putin versucht mit
fossilen Gas die demokratischen
Unterstützer der Ukraine zu spalten und
unsere Gesellschaft ist destabilisieren
aber wir sagen sehr klar das werden wir
als Koalition nicht zulassen
unterschätzen weiter die Ukraine die wir
lassen uns Wladimir Putin nicht spalten
und wir haben als Ampelkoalition in den
letzten Monaten zentrale Antworten auf
Putins Hybride Kriegsführung geleistet
wir haben die Gasspeicher zu 95% gefüllt
wir haben das größte Paket für
erneuerbaren Energien seit Jahrzehnten
im Bundestag beschlossen wir haben drei
entlastungspakete der Staatssekretär
darauf hingewiesen in Höhe von 95
Milliarden Euro beschlossen heute legen
wir eine weitere zentrale Antwort vor
ein 200 Milliarden Euro schweren
abwehrschirmen wir machen aus den
wirtschaftstabilisierungsfonds
zu Stabilisierung unserer Gesellschaft
und das sind 200 Milliarden Euro die
direkt ankommen die unsere gasversorge
stabilisieren die industriestabilisieren
die kleine mittlere Unternehmen helfen
sozialen Einrichtungen Kommunen und vor
allem die Bürgerinnen und Bürger vor den
schlimmsten Folgen der fossilen
Preissteigerung schützen wir sagen sehr
klar wir lassen sehr Krise niemanden
allein
und deswegen schlagen wir vor dass 200
Milliarden Euro an neuen Krediten im
Rahmen der Regeln des Grundgesetzes das
Artikel
115/2022 noch aufgenommen werden um die
Maßnahmen gegen fossile Inflation bei
gasfernwörner und Strom zu finanzieren
wir machen das auch in diesem Jahr noch
in voller Höhe um auf Verlässlichkeit
und überjährigkeit zu garantieren denn
diese Mitte sollen ja auch für mehrere
Jahre bis früher
2024 oder Mitte 2024 Verfügung stehen
wir gehen damit eben auch finanziell
jetzt weil es notwendig ist in
Vorleistung und zeigen damit dass wir
eine aktiven Finanzpolitik jenseits
ideologischer abonniertheit pragmatisch
entschlossen in der Krise handeln
und ich bin den Mitgliedern der
Expertenkommission für Gas und Wärme
dankbar dass sie es wirklich in der
extremen Zeitung
Zwischenbericht vorgelegt haben und ein
komplexen Vorschlag gearbeitet haben der
eine weitere gute Grundlage für unser
parlamentarisches Verfahren ist
natürlich ist es klar dass wir uns im
parlamentarischer fahren die Vorschläge
auch noch mal angucken müssen dass unser
Aufgaben im Parlament zu dem Sicherheit
noch einfach rechtliche Fragen geben es
geht um technische Details natürlich
werden wir in manchen Stellen auch
politisch eigene Akzente setzen müssen
zum Beispiel der Frage einer Obergrenze
auch insbesondere im Bereich der
Industrie und wir müssen auch nochmal um
das Thema Energieeffizienz und
Sparanreize reden denn eins ist auch
klar neben der Subventionierung auch der
Preise brauchen wir auch eine
gesamtgesellschaftliche Kraftanstrengung
zum Sparen von Gas eine Signal kann es
auch nicht sein mit dem Preis ist schon
alles gut wir müssen weiterhin zentral
dieser Krise gaseinspannung eine
gefährliche gasmangelage insbesondere
für die Industrie zu verhindern darum
ist jetzt auch in diesem Winter
und der Mittelberg sie haben gesagt die
Union unterstützt im Kern die Vorschläge
zur strompreisbremse und gaspreisbremse
gleichzeitig haben sie gesagt aber die
Finanzierung unterstützen sie nicht was
wollen denn stattdessen sie müssen auch
konkrete Vorschläge machen nur
kritisieren geht er nicht wollen sie
Steuern erhöhen wollen sie
Sozialkürzungen was wollen die konkret
sie müssen konkret hier Parlament sagen
was sie wollen das wäre seriöse
Finanzpolitik
und der Mitte Werk sie haben auch die
Atomkraft angesprochen Herr Merz sind
heute auch hier sind nur drei Tage vor
der Landtagswahl Niedersachsen gesagt
der Mittelberg und ich kommen wir beide
aus Niedersachsen wissen also sehr gut
wie die Lage dort ist Herr Merz immer
noch drei Tage oder Land Niedersachsen
gesagt die Wählerinnen und Wähler
entscheiden auch in dieser
Volksabstimmung über die Atomkraft das
Ergebnis ist bekannt die CDU hat das
schlechtes Ergebnis seit 65 Jahren die
Grünen haben das historisch beste
Ergebnis in ihrer Geschichte die
stärkste Kraft ist die SPD geworden es
gibt jetzt eine rot-grüne
Landesregierung wird es in Niedersachsen
geben Herr Merz die WählerInnen Wähler
haben sehr klar bei dieser
Volksabstimmung über Atomkraft
entschieden
und ehrlich
und Liebe Union lasst uns mal ehrlich
reden warum sind wir in dieser fossilen
Energiekrise das sieht auch daran dass
der 16 Jahre Energiepolitik der Union
hatten dann müssen Sie gar nicht lachen
ich komme zu den Fakten
alle in der Knick bei der Solarenergie
wir wissen auch dass sie versucht haben
jedes Windrads blockieren wo es geht und
in der Führung von Angela Merkel wurden
die gasspeichern Reden an gaskom
verkauft der Führung von Angela Merkel
wo der PTK Schwedt an Rossner verkauft
Nord Stream 2 wurde dafür von Angela
Merkel vorangetrieben das waren ihre 16
Jahre Regierungszeit Misere gebracht
haben wir räumen jetzt den Hochdruck auf
was sie uns alles erlassen haben
vielen Dank Sven Christian Kindler von
den Bündnis Gründen noch heute Haar
Abend haben die Grünen ihren Parteitag
das nennt sich bei den Grünen Bundes
Delegierten Konferenz in Bonn und
Phoenix meine Damen und Herren wird das
Ganze für sie live übertragen bis
Mitternacht und nehmen sich ein bisschen
Zeit heute Abend wird da heftigungen
werden um die Frage Atomkraft und das
alles wie gesagt hier bei uns auf diesem
Sender zu sehen Gesine lötz jetzt die
stellvertreten Fraktionsvorsitzende
Linksfraktion
kennen und Armutsbetroffene dürfen nicht
länger arm bleiben das ist die klare
Forderung der LINKEN und daran messen
wir jedes Gesetz meine Damen und Herren
besser verdienen und vermögene freuen
sich jetzt schon über die gaspreisbremse
Marcel Fratzscher Chef des Deutschen
Instituts für Wirtschaftsforschung legt
den Finger in die Wunde Menschen mit
hohem Einkommen werden viermal mehr Geld
als Menschen mit niedrigem Einkommen
erhalten sie wollen alles über den Preis
Regeln doch das ist der falsche Weg denn
es trifft vor allem die Menschen mit
unterem und mittleren Einkommen wir
brauchen andere Maßnahmen meine Damen
und Herren
ein Großteil des privaten
Energieverbrauchs lässt sich aber den
Menschen zuordnen die mehrere Häuser
besitzen Swimmingpools haben schwere SUV
oder
sportwarenfragen und die vor allem
häufig mit dem Flugzeug auch mit dem
Privatflugzeug verreisen warum also ganz
konkreter Vorschlag nicht im Winter alle
suv-sportwagen Luxusyachten und
privatrechtsstilllegen das wäre doch mal
eine wirksame konkrete Maßnahme meine
Damen und Herren ich sage der Koalition
ganz klar sie dürfen sich nicht weiter
als Vermögensverwalter der oberen
reichsten zehn Prozent der Bevölkerung
verstehen das werden wir nicht
akzeptieren meine Damen und Herren
die SPD und ihre diversen
Koalitionspartner haben schon viele
Bremsen entworfen funktioniert haben sie
für die große Mehrheit der Bürgerinnen
und Bürger alle nicht ich erinnere zum
Beispiel an die gescheiterte
mietpreisbremse die Wohnungsnot war noch
nie so groß wie heute sie haben ein
neues Ministerium geschaffen aber auf
die Wohnung warten wir immer noch das
ist wahrlich eine schlechte Bilanz meine
Damen und Herren die Energie
den ziehen und Lebensmittelpreise
explodieren wir brauchen endlich
wirksame preisdecke und dazu gehören die
Energiekonzerne endlich wieder in die
öffentliche Hand meine Damen und Herren
ich fordere Sie auf kuscheln sie nicht
vor den wohnungskonzernen den großen
Lebensmittelkonzern und den
energiemonopolen die Süddeutsche Zeitung
wahrlich Kampfblatt der Linken hat am
vergangenen Wochenende vorgerechnet wen
sie mit ihrer Energiepolitik brutal in
den Bankrott treiben und wer mit der
Energiepolitik kein Problem hat bringen
das auf den Punkt die reichsten zehn
Prozent der deutschen Haushalte
beanspruchen so viel Energie wie die
Ärmsten 40 Prozent und das wohlhabendste
Zehntel der Bevölkerung könnte auf einen
Schlag auf einen Schlag etwa 26 Prozent
des Energiebedarfs der deutschen
Haushalte einsparen wenn sie sich so
verhalten würden wie der
durchschnittlich wohlhabende Bürger das
wäre doch nicht zu viel verlangt meine
Damen und Herren also verbessern wir das
Gesetz mit konkreten Maßnahmen hören sie
auf ständig an die Allgemeinheit zu
appellieren sondern treffen sie dort
Entscheidungen wo sie wirksam sind
nämlich bei den reichsten in diesem Land
herzlichen Dank
für die SPD ich gucke jetzt noch mal
jawohl redet jetzt Nina Scheer sie ist
Sprecherin für Umwelt und Energie
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin Liebe
Kolleg
innen und einen Passus aus dem
Gesetzentwurf Vorlesen die Bürgerinnen
und Bürger sowie Unternehmen sollen
darauf vertrauen können Herr Mittelberg
ich bitte Sie kurz zuzuhören die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger sowie Unternehmen
sollen darauf vertrauen können dass der
Abwehrschirm mit ausreichenden
finanziellen Ressourcen ausgestattet ist
dieses Vertrauen dieses Vertrauen
sprechen wollen sie den Bürgerinnen und
Bürgern offenbar nicht geben weil sie
hier gerade grundsätzlich abgelehnt
haben diesen
Programms zuzustimmen weil sie offenbar
nicht für nötig halten dass dieses
Volumen erforderlich ist und genau
dieses Vertrauen zu gewährleisten um
genau dieses Vertrauen zu geben und das
finde ich im höchsten Maße irritierend
dass sie auf dieser Ebene in diesen
Zeiten ein solches Vertrauen den
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern nicht geben
wollen das möchte ich immer festhalten
die CDU CSU ist nicht bereit dieses
Vertrauen zu geben
und genau an diesem Vertrauen wird eben
dieses Gesetz an wir brauchen dieses
Gesetz um den
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds
auszustatten mit 200 Milliarden und eben
diese Möglichkeit damit zu geben Hilfen
die dann durch auszugestaltende
Programme auch wirklich umgesetzt werden
können insofern ist es auch falsch die
ist vom rechten Rand im Parlament hier
unterstellt wird dass hier quasi eine
Selbstentmachtung des Parlaments
stattfände nein das ist so nicht sondern
es ist eine zu Verfügungstellung mit
grundgesetzlich fundierter Basis für
diese 200 Milliarden weil wir alle nicht
wissen wie weit die Abhängigkeiten die
wir zurzeit von Russland noch hatten die
letzten Monate und in auf gutem Weg sind
uns davon zu befreien wie weit die Krise
die daraus auf dem fossilen Energiemarkt
erwachsen ist und von der wir uns
loslösen wollen wie weit diese Krise
auch finanz Bedarf für weitere fördern
erfordert und genau da setzen wir
verantwortungsbewusst
[Musik]
Vertrauen und zu Stabilisierung von
Vertrauen in Handlungsfähigkeit an
deswegen ist es erforderlich dass wir
diesen
stabilisierungsfond
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsform machen
und insofern kann man auch nur an alle
appellieren hier keine Fragezeichen zu
setzen weil damit sind sie nur
nährbodenberater für Angst und Angst ist
einfach genau das was dann wieder
ausgenutzt wird um unsere
parlamentarische Demokratie auszuhüllen
damit geben sie sich in sehr schlechte
Gesellschaft wenn Sie diese Angst weiter
spüren
wir haben in dieser Situation wir haben
eine ernste Situation und diese
ernstesituation verlangen zum Beispiel
auch dass wir über den Teich blicken und
schauen was andere Staaten und
Kontinente machen wir haben in den USA
ein Inflation reaction
reduction Act es wird reagiert auf
Inflation es wird reagiert auf die Krise
ist wird es wird darauf reagiert dass
wir eine Klimakrise haben und massiv
investiert wenn wir nicht aufpassen dann
kam diese sinnvolle Maßnahme die die USA
ergreifen auch bedeuten dass in dieser
steigenden Inflation die wir in Europa
haben aufgrund der fossilen
energiepreiskrise dass wir daraufhin
verstärkt Schwierigkeiten bekommen auch
Investitionen in erneuerbaren Energien
in den Transformationsprozess den wir
haben deswegen ist es dringend nötig
dass wir Stabilisierungsmaßnahmen auf
den Weg bringen weitere
Stabilisierungsmaßnahmen wir haben ja
schon gehandelt die auch kräftig genug
sind dass diese fortschreitende
Inflation eingedämmt wird dafür muss man
bei den Energiepreisen in Form von
Gaspreisen strompreisbremse ansetzen
damit dieser Weg gestoppt wird dass die
Inflation gestoppt wird dass wieder
investiert werden kann auch in die
Transformation massiv investiert werden
kann weil sonst droht uns tatsächlich
Abwanderung in auch solche Länder die
jetzt ein Booster ansetzen und angesetzt
haben gerade um diesen
Transformationsprozess zu beschleunigen
wir müssen hier gleich aufbleiben mit
diesen Bemühungen die auch an anderer
Stelle bleiben damit wir wirtschaftlich
nicht da
benachteiligt sind in Deutschland und
Europa Deutschland ist ein
Hochtechnologie
wir wollen das bleiben mit Europa in
Europa und in Deutschland das heißt im
Transformationsprozess massive
Investitionen in erneuerbare Energien
und wenn sie von Seiten der Union immer
wieder versuchen der bevöl Sand in die
Augen zu streuen das Atomenergie hier
die Lösung sei da möchte ich doch mal
ganz erklärtermaßen dagegen setzen dass
diese drei verbleibenden Atomkraftwerke
und nur die zwei haben hat der
Stresstest in die identifiziert im Süden
Deutschlands dass sie nur einen
minimalen Beitrag für den allergrößten
Worst Case zeichnen können und wir haben
gerade
erst in dem Deutschen Bundestag
beschlossen einen erneuerbaren Energien
Booster der übrigens noch nicht vom
Stress-Test mit
berücksichtigt werden konnte darin haben
wir eine verstärkte Auslastung von
Bioenergie beschlossen wir haben eine
verstärkte Auslastung von Windenergie
und für Photovoltaik reparing alles
dergleichen beschlossen insofern
versuchen Sie nicht hier nicht
Nebelkerzen zu werfen die Energiewende
die Energiewende ist das Ziel und der
Weg um diese Krise zu bewältigen und
hierfür brauchen wir den
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds und
diese Fragezeichen die sie hier setzen
sind nur die Stabilisierung und
Angstmacherei das ist unverantwortlich
vielen Dank
erste Lesung der Bundestag wird den
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds der noch
aus corona-zeiten übrig ist mit einer
kreditermischung noch in diesem Jahr von
200 Milliarden Euro ausstatten darum
geht es hier in dieser Debatte die jetzt
gleich enden wird mit dem letzten Redner
Florian Osna von der CSU
Kinder liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
die
preisöle
Pellets und Strom schießen seit Monaten
durch die Decke und was macht die Ampel
während der gesamten Sommerzeit
nichts nichts anstatt für Entlastung bei
den Bürgern zu sorgen hat der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister Robert Habeck
den ich übrigens heute vermisse übrigens
viele der Bundesminister aus seine
einzige Bundesministerin die see also
für 200 Milliarden Euro doppelbums hätte
mir gedacht wäre ist höher priorisiert
seitens der Bundesregierung
anstatt für Entlastungen bei den Bürgern
zu sorgen hat Bundeswirtschaftsminister
Habeck von den Grünen ja sogar noch mit
einer von ihm erdachten Gas Umlage eine
zusätzliche Belastung beschlossen das
ist wirklich keine uns ein Land mit
gesunden Menschenverstand
nachvollziehbar es war deshalb mehr als
überfällig unter Druck der cdocs zu
bundestagsreaktion zumindest diese
Zusatz transalierung gasumlage für
unsere bürgeradakter zu legen
insofern ist der sieben Grundsatz
richtig dass du ein überhaupt eine
Entlastung für die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger und Unternehmen in unserem Land
kommt allerdings sollte man nicht von
einem doppelwumms sprechen sondern eher
von einem schuldenwumms denn dieser
sogenannte Abwehrschirm ist nichts
weiter als ein gigantischer
Schattenhaushalt der mit einer
Schuldenaufnahme über 200 Milliarden
Euro die Hamsterbacken der Ampel füllt
diese Schulden müssen auch irgendwann
abbezahlt werden 60 Milliarden Euro aus
dem alten Jahr 140 Milliarden Euro
corona-schulden 100 Milliarden
sonderschulden Bundeswehr und nur
nochmals 200 Milliarden Euro
Krisenintervention in Summe eine halbe
Billion Euro in diesem Jahr als ein
kompletter Bundeshaushalt das gleicht
schon einer Öffnung aller
schuldenschleusen für uns als Ziele und
CSU muss deshalb unbedingt eine
komplette neu Priorisierung des
Bundeshaushalts vorgenommen
Herr Oster gestatten Sie eine Frage vom
Kollegen schrodi aus der SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrter Oster vielen Dank dass Sie
die Frage zulassen wir haben jetzt von
Reden an der cdu/csu-fraktion jetzt
mehrmals gehört dass sie ja
grundsätzlich richtig finden dass es
Entlastungen gibt dass es Hilfsprogramme
gibt für die Unternehmen unserem Land
für die Menschen unter unserem Land die
und in hohen Preisen leiden wir bringen
das nun auf dem Weg aber gleichzeitig
sagen sie sie sind nicht einverstanden
mit der Finanzierung dieser notwendigen
Programme aber sie haben jetzt mehrmals
bei mehreren Rednern kann der einzige
Alternative aufgemacht wie sie nun diese
Programme finanzieren sie wollen weder
Steuern erhöhen noch wollen sie mit
neuen Kreditprogrammen das ganze auf den
Weg bringen die Frage ist wenn sie
einerseits solche Dinge versprechen und
andererseits seit Monaten eine Antwort
schuldig sind wie sie es finanzieren
wollen dann ist das unseriöse
Finanzpolitik die sie sich in der
Opposition leisten können aber nicht wir
eine Frage ganz konkret wie wollen sie
es finanzieren
ja sehr geehrte Herr Kollege vielen Dank
für die für frage sie haben sich selbst
schon fast die Antwort gegeben sie haben
in dem Instrumentarium Kasten der SPD
benannt dass man entweder Steuern erhöht
oder dass man selbst neue Schulden
aufnimmt aber es gibt es gibt auch noch
andere Möglichkeiten nämlich eine neue
Priorisierung des Haushalts ich denke
wir haben wir hatten diese Woche wir
hatten diese Woche
wir hatten diese Woche ein Bürgergeld
ein Bürgergeld diskutiert ich denke es
ist eine Unzeit in dieser Zeit ein
Bürgergeld über Millionen und Milliarden
in diesem Land zu beschließen statt eine
neue Priorisierung des Bundeshaushalts
vorzunehmen
bevor wir jetzt hier ist kein
Zwiegespräch glaube er hat die Frage
wann Herr Rosner es gibt aber noch eine
Frage vom Kollegen Fricke aus der
FDP-Fraktion würden sie die auch noch
zulassen wir auch noch zu sehr gerne
Herr Fricke sie haben das Wort
Herr Kollege weil ich die kluge Frage
meines Kollegen schrodi ja verstehe ich
aber mit der Antwort auch nicht
zufrieden bin und ich auch nicht bisher
im Haushaltsausschuss in den Beratung
auch nicht in dieser Woche erlebt habe
dass die cdu/csu auch nur einen Antrag
wirklich zur neu Priorisierung gestellt
hat versuche ich es
versuche ich es
mit einer vielleicht ganz einfachen
Frage ich habe dem Kollegen Mittelberg
zugehört ich habe ihnen zugehört da wird
gesagt ja das muss alles anders ich habe
aber etwas nicht gehört was man sonst in
ihren Reden immer so deutlich und klar
hört gerade von der stolzen CSU werden
sie denn dann den Gesetzentwurf jetzt
ablehnen oder bekomme ich jetzt von
ihnen ein weiches jein weil er neu
priorisieren
sehr geehrter Herr Kollege Fricke auch
daher herzliches Dankeschön für Ihre
Frage also erstmal um die Frage
beantworten zu können ob wir zustimmen
können müssen wir genau wissen was
wirklich am Ende umgesetzt wird hier
lassen Sie es derart viele Fragezeichen
die selbst Vorredner ihrer
Ampelkoalition schon bereits bestätigt
haben zweitens wir hatten in allen
Haushaltsdebatten immer ganz klar auch
die Gegenfinanzierung mit angebracht
teilweise sogar mit einer Größen
Gegenfinanzierung im Gegensatz zur Ampel
die immer nur zusätzliche Beschlüsse on
top auf den bestehenden Haushalt gesetzt
hat im Gegensatz zu ihnen wissen wir
sehr wohl mit den öffentlichen Geldern
umzugehen
ob die ob die Schulden Ausnahmesituation
auf wären wir beim Punkt des Artikels
115 für den Wirtschaft
stabilisierungsform Ende wirklich greift
bleibt noch zu klären exogene Notlagen
wieder Energie Engpass durch den Ukraine
Krieg liegen vor jedoch muss der Bund
nicht wehrlos zuschauen Stichwort
Kernkraftwerke und da möchte gerne auf
meine Vorreden als wenn Christian Kinder
von den Grünen reagieren als aus grüner
auf andere mit erhobenen Zeigefinger zu
deuten ist echt mehr als gewagt denn ab
Baden-Württemberg hat von allen
Flächenländern die wenigsten
Windkraftanlagen ist aber bekannterweise
seit 2011 von einem grünen Minister von
einem grünen Ministerpräsident
Kretschmann regiert Bayern im Gegensatz
das seit 1957 durchgehend von der c- zu
regiert ist hat die höchste Quote an
regenerativen Energien da können sich
selbst beantworten welche politischen
Voraussetzungen am Ende
die Krise muss definitiv abgefedert
werden und es zwingt uns natürlich
verzichtbarer Projekte im Kernhaushalt
einzusparen ich habe es vorher schon
benannt beispielsweise Bürgergeld denn
es anders als uns insbesondere die
Grünen in den letzten Tagen immer wieder
weiß machen wollen kommt das Geld eben
einfach nicht von einer politisch
gelenkten Zentralbank und man kann auch
sehr wohl in seiner eigenen Währung man
höre pleite gehen wer die Grundsätze
einer unabhängigen Zentralbank aufgibt
geht den Weg in die hypeinflation den
wirtschaftlichen Niedergang in
Deutschland mehrmals in der Geschichte
erlebt hat das ist mit uns als cducs so
nicht zu machen
bekämpfen als Union für eine Entlastung
der bürgerunternehmen jedoch ist es
nicht nachvollziehbar nach welcher
Kalkulation frau Präsidentin komme zum
Schluss auf die Summe von 200 Milliarden
Euro kommt ist bleibt völlig offen wie
Gas und Strompreise schlussendlich
ausgestaltet werden soll Öl und Pellets
wollen völlig was aus meiner Sicht
gerade den ländlichen Traum trifft keine
Frage ich will die Herausforderung nicht
kleinredene sie ist gigantisch wir
laufen in eine Industrialisierung
unseres Landes mit unabsehbaren Folgen
für Wohlstand und der deutschen
Zukunftsfähigkeit wir werden uns einer
konstruktiven Zusammenarbeit deshalb
nicht verschließen unsere Zustimmung
lieber Otto Fricke hängt am Ende aber
von der konkreten Ausgestaltung ab
herzliches Vergelt's Gott fürs zuhören
Florian ossen hat gesagt die CDU CSU
möchte erstmal wissen was am Schluss in
diesem Gesetz dann drinsteht in dem
Wirtschaft Stabilisierungsfonds soll
nicht nur eine Kredit Ermächtigung von
200 Milliarden Euro
ausgestattet werden sondern auch die
Regelungen zu Finanzierung der geplanten
Hilfen muss darin festgehalten werden
und die sind ja noch alles andere als
klar das war aber heute erst der erste
Gesetzentwurf es geht jetzt in den
entsprechenden Ausschüsse und man muss
jetzt warten welche Gesetze im Einzelnen
und wie es im einzelnen mit der
gaspreisbremse zum Beispiel aussieht das
wird ja noch ein wenig auf sich warten
lassen